hello freak bitches wouldn't dry ice
burn your dick well that's some people
like that shit doc 20 years ago I went
to a club to get quaaludes and I walked
in I'll never forget it's like I was
called ramrod there was a gay bar in the
city we were kids we were like 18 that's
the first time I seen a dude with a cape
on I thought it was the coolest fucking
thing in the world a man had a cape on
and I walked into this club and before
we walked in there was a fetish club on
the side there was a guy in a tub that
had a sign on him that said spit on me
that was his fetish for people to spit
on so here's the beauty I'm standing
there you know your jaw is going you're
drinking you know you had a pee and
Austin I see 20 guys standing on line
for the fucking bathroom I asked one I
go listen well let's just ask the guy in
the tub if we could pee on so I walked
over to a guy who can I ask a question
do you mind if we pee annually guys go
right ahead
there was a point that night I looked at
him he had a circle of guys just you
know those guys don't want wait on line
like fucking just pee on when I left the
guy had three inches of pee in the
fucking tub the sign was all fucking
melted like the black ink was been
melted it was this guy wanted people to
spit on him we into the pissin on and I
pissed on and I'm guilty of I don't give
a fuck it in suck my dick Allah
I would piss on anybody I don't give a
fuck he seems like the luckiest man oh
please but that's a crazy ass fetish but
you never know some people's chicken is
another man's gumbo you understand I
don't like pissing up myself but this
guy wanted you to businessman on what is
that that's crazy shit that's crazy shit
that when I was in Seattle on Wednesday
nights at the comedy club they had a
fetish club afterward and there's a
couple times I stayed people fucking
crazy it ain't my bag of tricks you know
I'm crazy it but like clips on the
nipples and all that I'm not into that
fucking shit but some some people are
where's all that shit coming from what's
all that come from I don't know the same
people who are in hoarders I don't know
I don't know these people fucking come
just a broken brain like someone who
just wants to shock the shit out of
everybody no no like sometimes you're
sitting there going wow I need some
action in my sex life fucking people in
the ass just say enough no boy somebody
go around and have people piss all over
me yeah like all that shit oh boy calm
down me fuck man like my boy and it
wasn't really the guy that wasn't what
with the guy's intentions
the guy just wanted people to spit on
him Wow I just took it to the next level
[Music]
[Applause]